a small but vocal group of Ukrainian
activists demonstrates outside the
European Council demanding their country
is admitted to the EU while there is
little chance of that anytime soon what
leaders inside the council have given
them is another demonstration of support
and a critical view of the Wagner Mutiny
last weekend this showed deep cracks in
Putin's system this Mutiny of last
weekend will also have aftershocks
the more it is important that we double
down on the support for Ukraine be it
military capability or financial support
already this week the EU has increased
by a third the amount of money it makes
available to Kiev with some officials
saying this support may need to be made
permanent but if there is a Unity of
purpose regarding Ukraine one issue
where there isn't is migration a deal
agreed by EU interior ministers in
Luxembourg three weeks ago was only
passed by a qualified majority of votes
One Nation with objections to it was
Poland
here in Brussels its prime minister
spelled out a different Vision
we have an alternative plan a plan of
securing Europe's borders and I will
present it here and it will be about
reinforcing frontex which is also
signaling that illegal immigration
indirectly supports smuggling groups it
supports de facto terrorism in Europe it
is enough to look at what frontex writes
in its report
but on the other side of the arguments
are countries like Italy who see the
Tunisia deal agreed with the EU as a
blueprint for the future elsewhere
relations with one other country have
loomed large over this Summit China seen
by EU leaders simultaneously as a
partner a competitor and a systemic
rival the mood music now suggests these
ministers are trying to downplay
divisions with Beijing with the hope the
government there might use its influence
in Moscow to end the war in Ukraine
Dominic Kane Al Jazeera Brussels
ahead of the meetings in Brussels NATO's
Secretary General insisted that support
for Ukraine will continue
immediate and Urgent task is to support
Ukraine to ensure that Ukraine prevails
as a sovereign independent nation in
Europe because unless we are able to do
that there is no membership issue to be
discussed at all and let me also mention
that this is also where uh where an area
where we see a link with the European
Union because of course the the EU
decision to Grant uh Ukraine candidate
status of course also has an impact on
the discussions which are taking place
within uh NATO together with the
European Union NATO allies have provided
unprecedented support and and and we are
stepping up just over the last weeks we
have seen a new announcements from EU
but also from NATO allies of additional
support and also the training of the
F-16 parties have started
senior director of geopolitics at
Rasmussen Global and he joins us from
Brussels Harry I want to pick up on
something
um from what Mr stoltenberg were saying
and what our correspondent Dominic Kane
were saying do you see Ukraine ever
becoming a member of the European Union
that's one or a member of NATO
absolutely I think both European union
and NATO membership are definitely
something that first of all uh Ukraine
uh is aspiring to do and it's enshrining
its Constitution and I think that given
the current context it is something that
we can see going forward of course it's
not going to be something that's going
to happen overnight but it's definitely
more of a prospect now than it was
before this war and I think it sends a
strong message to Putin that while he
won it and he may have wanted to keep
Ukraine away from its European past he's
achieving the opposite you really think
the EU would bring in Ukraine I'm not
talking now but say medium term you
really think the EU would bring in
Ukraine you really think NATO would
bring in Ukraine at this not right now
again not right now medium term
absolutely I think first of all you see
already a sign and the fact that Ukraine
is a candidate
has a candidate status
um uh with the EU something that yeah
but tortilla also had candidate had a a
membership bid at some point and that
went nowhere
it went nowhere for now let's see yes
but I think in Ukraine's case we have a
definite momentum building up and again
I'm not saying it's going to happen
overnight but definitely it's something
in in that you know has a chance of
happening within you know let's see how
long it's going to take when it comes to
Nato I think the same the same the same
thing is true and we're gonna look to
the villainous Summit to see what the
language will be among the allies and
again I don't think we're going to see
an invite necessarily at the NATO Summit
but I think we're going to definitely
see some language that will point to uh
to Ukraine's path towards NATO at some
point
and European Union countries are
discussing at this Summit their support
for Ukraine the nature the amount the
quantity of the support for Ukraine do
you think that they're going to reach a
higher level of support they're already
providing weapons not all the weapons
that Ukraine wants but a fair few of
them and ammunition
absolutely I think you're seeing a
definitely more money being discussed
more uh a higher level of ambition put
on the table and at the same time while
we are talking about uh uh some language
on on NATO membership and and some type
of of let's say path forward for
Ukrainian NATO membership I think you're
also seeing discussions on security
guarantees for Ukraine in the interim
period not to replace NATO membership
but to to serve as an interim solution
while Ukraine is seeking NATO membership
and I think there's a very strong role
for the EU in that Harry nadelko senior
director of geopolitics at Rasmussen
Global thank you
thank you